let G of X equal negative 4x plus 7 what
is the value of the limit as X
approaches negative 1 of all of this so
before we think about this let's just
visualize the line and then we can think
about what they're asking here so let me
draw some axes here so this is my
vertical axis and this is my horizontal
axis my horizontal axis and let's say
that this is my x-axis we'll label out
the x axis I'll graph G of X G of X is
going to have a positive I guess we
could say y-intercept or vertical axis
intercept it's going to have a slope of
negative 4 so it's going to look
something like this let me draw my best
so it's going to look something
something like that and we already know
that the slope the slope here is going
to be negative 4 we get that right from
this slope-intercept form of the
equation slope is equal to negative 4
and they asked us what is the limit as X
approaches negative 1 of all of this
kind of stuff so let's plot the point
negative 1 so when X is negative 1 so
that's this point right over here and
this point right over here would be the
point negative 1 comma G of negative 1
and let me label everything else so I
could call this my y-axis I could call
this graph this is the graph of y is
equal to G of X so what they're doing
right over here is they're finding the
slope between an arbitrary point X G of
X and this point right over here so
let's do that so let's take another X so
let's say this is X this would be the
point this would be the point X G of X
and this expression right over here
notice it is your change in the vertical
axis your change in the vertical axis
that would be your G of X let me make it
this way so this would be your your
change in the vertical axis that would
be G of X minus G of negative 1 and then
that's over actually let me write it
this way so that you can keep track of
the colors minus G of negative 1 all of
that over your change in the horizontal
axis well your change in the horizontal
axis
is this distance this distance which is
the same thing as this distance notice
your change in vertical over change in
horizontal change in vertical over
change in horizontal we're viewing the
Green Point as the end point so it's
going to be X minus negative one and
these this is the exact same expression
these are the exact same expression you
could simplify the minus negative one
and this becomes plus this could become
a plus one but these are the exact same
expression so this is the expression
really for the slope between negative
one and G of negative one and an
arbitrary X well we already know that
that no matter what X you you pick the
slope between XG of X and this point
right over here is going to be constant
it's going to be the slope of the line
it's going to be equal to negative four
this thing is going to be equal to
negative four it's going to be equal to
negative four doesn't matter how close
how close X gets and whether X comes
from a bit from the right or there X
comes from the left so this thing taking
the limit of this this just gets you to
negative four it's really just the slope
of the line so even if you were to take
the limit as X approaches negative one
this X gets closer and closer and closer
to negative one well then these points
are just going to get closer and closer
and closer but every time you calculate
the slope it's just going to be the
slope of the line which is negative four
now you could also do this algebraically
and let's try to do it algebraically so
let's actually just take the limit the
limit as X approaches negative one of G
of X well they already told us what G of
X is it is negative 4x plus seven minus
G of negative one so that's minus what
is G of negative one negative one times
4 is positive 4 positive 4 plus seven is
1111 all of that over all of that over X
plus 1 all of that over X plus 1 and
that's really that's where it's really X
minus negative 1 is if you want to think
of it that way but
just write x plus one this way here so
this is going to be equal to the limit
as X approaches negative 1 of in our
numerator let's see 7 minus 11 is
negative 4 we can factor out a negative
4 it's negative 4 times X plus 1 all of
that over X plus 1 and then since we're
just trying to find the limit as X
approaches negative 1 so we can we can
cancel those out and what this is going
to be this is going to be nonzero for
any X for any x value other than
negative 1 and so this is going to be
equal to negative 4 so either way we get
negative 4 but if you just realize hey
this is a line it's going to have a
constant slope this is just the slope of
between some arbitrary point on the line
and the point negative 1 comma 11 really
or negative 1 comma 11 you say well
that's just going to be the same as the
slope of line it's negative 4